right welcome
um I hope everybody enjoyed their lunch
and that the last people are finding
Siege otherwise otherwise fill in the
gaps so everybody can can be here
there's more people than expected
um that's good I guess
um well the title of the talk is uh
effective testing in microservice
systems but I guess you already know
that because you're here and you can
read and everything
um but anyway that is the title of the
title of talk
um
my name is Christian
um I wrote this microservices book and
much of what I'll talk about today is in
here not all of it but that is and
there's a lot of content surrounding the
topic that I'm talking about today in
here as well I brought two copies so the
first people who asked for them after
the talk will get those if you want them
um that's not the point the point is the
talk so
um
it was effective testing in microservice
systems so the first question here that
pops up is what should we test and well
it sounds like a very concrete question
I guess it is but the answer might not
be quite as concrete but we'll slowly
get there get into that as we move
through this Hawk
um but really I think it's very much
about testing enough to have confidence
to deploy to production and that means
different things for different systems
there are different
consequences to different systems
getting it wrong in production so
there's different tolerance of risk but
you need at least but overall no matter
what the tolerance or risk is you need
the confidence to actually deploy to
production otherwise you're just stuck
in in your test environment that's
that's no good
so that's something we want we also want
a
a the maintenance effort to be sensical
so you can't you can't spend all your
time uh writing tests or doing manual
tests for that that matter we probably
can't spend zero time either that
probably wouldn't give you the
confidence to to deploy
um and then well there's not really a
what to test but it's a why is testing a
a separate topic when we talk about
microservices is that that you quickly
when you move into microservice get
hundreds of of services well maybe not
quickly actually I think in my
experience looks like people spend like
the six months building the first
microservice and then they built six
months building five more and then it
accelerates then six months after that
they have a hundred and then they have
then it just goes up from there so they
really accelerate and and you probably
need to get on top of your testing
strategy before you have 300 services in
in production right
um
because if you have that many you you
sort of can't really just sort of bring
it up all locally and just uh test out
everything in all combinations of of
everything that's not really an option
uh
um with that many moving parts and that
many services so we we sort of have to
attack it slightly differently than that
and that's what we will get into
but first
um we need to detour a little bit and
just very quickly talk a little bit
about what a microservice is in my world
at least I think you can find lots of
different definitions so what I'm going
by is that the microservice is something
that is responsible for a single
capability it's individually Deployable
so you can deploy one without deploying
the whole world and all of it so that
testing enough to have confidence to
deploy that's about well you deploy one
at a time so I have to have the
confidence that you can actually do that
that you don't have to orchestrate all
of it all at once
um
yeah so there can be more than one
Deployable unit that's not really that
employer that uh
important in this context
um
there's a data store associated with
each and every one of them
um that has some impact on the testing
strategy
and well in terms of size
um a small team can handle
well actually a few handfuls of of
services and this is like really gray
area
um what that actually means but I think
it it gives a feel for the kind of size
that we're that we're looking at and the
kind of of things that we're looking at
um and they are replaceable in the sense
that since they are so focused it's
actually possible to to say oh that was
the wrong technology we're going to
implement it in some something else and
do that in the normal pace of work
without spending the big replacement
um a project that never ends so that's
also something that you sort of have to
probably take into consideration with
testing that that you need to support
this tenant as well
okay so making it a bit more concrete
and and having a bit uh of example of of
what a microservice might do
um because I think that impacts the
testing effort quite a lot
um we can think about a loyalty program
so uh
whatever chain of stores you might be
able to think about you can have like an
app or plastic card and then every time
you buy something you get loyalty points
and then they try to make you buy even
more or stuff like that
um
many companies have these you probably
know about them right so you could have
this loyalty program the green one in
the middle and it has some connections
to to some other microservices and the
exact connections here are not that
important
um the ones that we're concentrating on
today is in the upper left hand corner
there's the uh left up there sorry there
um that's the special offers
microservice so you could imagine that
as a back office UI something where
and somebody can put in a special offer
and say on Saturday you can get three
for the price of two then the Loyalty
program picks that up as an event says
okay who's interested in that and
everybody in the Loyalty program who we
think are interested in that we give
them a notification email text whatever
and say okay go buy our fabulous stuff
because this is something you usually uh
usually buy so this is sort of an
approximation that loyalty program
that's the first approximation of how we
might break a part a small part of this
system into some some microservices so
this is trying to make it a bit more
concrete what we're talking about
and why exactly that well because the
scope of a microservice should really be
driven by business capabilities so a
microservice should be responsible for a
single business capability and this is
important in terms of testing because
that means that that now we're talking
about something that we can talk about
how should work with that isn't
technical is actually business and
that's what we want to test
um that we want to test that capability
um now what does the capability mean
that's a little bit difficult and that's
why I said that the Loyalty program is
kind of the first approximation because
if you drive into it it tends to be that
that there's more things inside of what
you might at first think is a good uh
capability so if you do some I don't
know brainstorming event storming you do
do some of these different
um ideation techniques
um or just really go talk to the
business or your well the business Tech
is hopefully part of the business go
talk to other parts of the business and
probably usually find out that there
there are more details to things so off
the top of my head a loyalty program
there's something about issuing and
canceling these plastic cards there's
something about awarding these loyalty
points you might decide that everybody
with a lots of points we organize a
monthly raffle and they can win some
something something
or they might be eligible to these
special offers based on their points and
their interests and stuff like that or
you might even organize special events
like
the car dealership that loves you will
invite you for a golf because then they
hope you buy an extra car or something
it could be smaller things as well
but that could be different things right
so it could probably turn out that
loyalty program might over time not
actually be a service but it's a
boundary context which is I'm taking
from a domain driven design
onto sort of a grouping of of these
services that kind of belong together
and form a cohesive all and then some of
these that we haven't had on the
previous slide might actually be the
capabilities that we have in different
services so my point in showing this
even though we're actually talking about
testing is that it sort of turns out
that that that a microservice system
evolves over time as does any system and
what you'll see is that you'll have
different areas of the system that look
at different in terms of the breakdown
and the size and we can use that to
guide some of our testing efforts as
well
so
when we drive into what something really
means and how it should really work and
we want to experiment with it and we
want to develop it and it's important
for the business it tends to get broken
more down so that might be the the
green one over there
that has smaller Services inside of it
because we've worked in more detail with
it than the red one at the bottom well
there might be something more emergent
that we're we're not that certain about
yet so we have a slightly bigger service
and then sort of some someone some some
smaller ones beside it because we're not
quite sure yet how to chop this up in a
really good way
um and we're not maybe sure of the
importance yet either and then the blue
one might be just something that we just
buy from a third party because it's just
generic for us so
again and DDD trims this might be the
core domain and this might be a
supporting subdomain and this might be
like a generic third-party thing a
generic subdomain
and
already here we can sort of think about
okay where do we really want to
concentrate the test efforts we probably
want it around the the core
and secondarily around the the
supporting subdomain of course we want
to test everything and want to be really
good around everything but we don't live
in a perfect world
um so so maybe sometimes we actually do
have to prioritize just a little bit and
I think concentrating on the core is
probably a good idea when it comes to
testing as well
so
okay so now let's get into two two tests
and we'll just start off with the uh
with with this the test pyramid I'm sure
you've seen it before it's been around
for a long time quite classic we have uh
unit test at the bottom
um then we have a middle layer and on
top we have and then the top layer we
have system tests and in the middle one
on these slides I've written service
tests and that's not usually what it
says there it usually says something
like integration tests that's probably
often what you would have seen but when
it comes to testing microservices
I think it's
I think it makes more sense uh at least
when you sort of get over the the hump
of seeing it a little bit differently to
talk about service tests because a
service test uh
is well something that tests a
microservice and and if we look at this
picture again we can see at least in the
core those are some quite small ones and
yeah there might be some integration
anyway going on but it's it's kind of a
nice testable unit so I think I've
already said that's the one thing you
should remember from the talk that one
microservice is actually a quite nice
testable unit
um system level tests those are
I don't think they are that different
when we talk about a microservice system
compared to a monolithic system or a
more traditional solar system where we
have bigger Services they are black bugs
so they don't know how things are
implemented so it really shouldn't be
that different based on what the area
how it's it's implemented they test the
complete system and
I am my recommendation is usually that
those could cover the most important
happy path use cases not all use cases
because it tends to be too much
maintenance effort but again what are
the most important that that depends on
the how risk averse we are in a com in a
given situation
um compared to well the consequences and
so on
um but as I said I don't think the
effort putting into to system level
tests is so different because it's uh
it's microservices so I'm not going to
talk more about those that doesn't mean
I don't think they have a role to play I
do it's just not different where based
on whether it's uh it's a monolith or
it's microservices
these the service levels that's the
middle middle level I think are very
different when it comes to
a a microservice system so we can test a
complete microservice and I think that's
what we should do at this level
um we can have the other services be
stopped or marked depending on which
word you you prefer just meaning that
we'll have fake versions of the of the
other microservices
um
and I sometimes think about these as
sort of a gray box so we have the Black
Box white box uh terminology and this is
sort of gray and in between because
um it's from the outside of the of the
microservice we test the whole
microservice so if the microservice were
a system it was an end-to-end complete
Survey System test but it's not we
there's there's dependencies and
collaboration between these different
microservices and since we are mocking
the other microservices we do know
something about the implementation not
inside of the microservice but inside
but in in part of the system so it's
kind of a gray in between thing here
um
and I think with this level
um we can cover
all the important scenarios for that
service meaning all the important
scenarios for that business capability
so that comes back to why I wanted to
point out that the scope and
responsibility of a microservice should
really be a business capability because
this is something that we can that we
can
put on a slightly higher level of
abstraction than than the technology and
the implementation but I actually talk
about what's important in terms of say a
loyalty program which scenarios should
it really really always support
and as opposed to system where I tend to
mostly go for the positive heavy path uh
things this can easily be this also can
can include uh negative things failures
of of different kinds
um right so
another thing that we could notice from
that
I'll just jump back to it from
oh
there we go from uh this picture is that
there's a lot of arrows between these
things now depending on what those
arrows mean we can have a higher or
lower coupling so even though there are
a lot of arrows we can have nice low
coupling but it does mean that there is
collaboration going on between these uh
the these microservices and it does mean
that if we just take one of the white
boxes and isolate then we can know a lot
about how well that one works but what
does it tell about the system well it
tells us
something but we don't really know about
the arrows so I think that's another
thing that happens when we move from
either traditional zoa or monolith and
to watch microservices is that we take
some of the complexity that we already
have in our code bases and then we move
it sort of outside of the code base it
says into the collaboration so we move
it from the code base and onto the
network
be it cues or trpc or HTTP apis no
matter what I mean we're we're moving it
from how the code works and how to how
the code communicates but that doesn't
mean the complexity is gone we've just
moved it so we want to look at covering
that as well
uh let's just jump
um
so once we're here where we were before
we we've covered the service but we
haven't covered the arrows and that's
why we want to supplement this with the
with contract tests with exactly cover
the the the the arrows so I think this
what we've summarized on this slide I
think is really uh the new thing when it
comes to having good test automation
around microservices compared to uh
um to other architectures
unit testing
um is the last part of the pyramid
still important but just like the system
tests not that much changes just because
you move to to microservices
usually test a unit of behavior
I'm pausing here because I think that's
important and it continues to be
misunderstood so we're not testing a
class we're not testing a function we're
testing a unit of behavior and it
doesn't really matter if it takes two
classes to implement that behavior so
you don't have to like have the exact
same structure in like the production
code and the test code doesn't have to
be one to one that's the same files all
over because then you'll really hamper
your ability to refactor so don't do
that focus on Behavior please
um and try to avoid mocks don't Mark too
much
you just end up fighting the mocking
Frameworks instead of delivering actual
code
this might be the last thing I'm going
to say about you and says there might be
one most lighter candidate I can
remember but that's about it because
again this isn't that different
um
so on to these service level tests again
and let's look a little bit more at it
so back to the example as well with the
Loyalty program and we're now back to
the state where we haven't done the
further breakdown of the Loyalty program
we just see it as one large program the
company has decided we need a loyalty
program so for now it's one thing and
then we might discover that it's more
than one thing as we as we go
so well demo is maybe overstating it but
I'm going to show you a little bit
outside of the slides
um so we have a loyalty program running
it has some some HTTP endpoints it's not
that
it's not that advanced really there's a
post endpoint to register users and
that's
my mouse
which we can open there and then
when we register somebody we can sort of
register a few interests so
they might be interested in
basketball and
I don't know children's books or
something like that for some reason
then
we have another service running we have
the special offers one it's really not
doesn't do that much and it has this
fantastic UI that I know
every business person would love
um that allows them to create a special
offer and they can't really do that much
they can describe the special offer and
then they can put some tags on and those
tags will match against the the
interests of people in the Loyalty
program so if they make a special offer
for children's books then the person
talked about before might get a
notification saying hey we have a good
offer for uh for children's books
when something is posted into this
endpoint
um what the special offers service does
is that it places something onto AQ I've
just used rapid mq here it's not about
which technology it's just some queuing
system
um that says hey there's a new special
offer so special offer created and then
we have more back back actually
oh there we go the larger program sorry
for all the switching uh back to the
Loyalty program so this one will listen
on that revlim q q and get the special
offer match it against the interests of
whoever's registered and then lastly the
lodge program will call this post
endpoint on the notification service and
then the responsibility of this service
to actually notify people via however
they want to be notified
whether they prefer email or text
message or whatever okay so
um I'm not going to go through posting
into these because that's not really
that interesting
um and well it works
um so back to the slide so let's talk
about if we had that system so right now
we sort of just have that system we've
thrown it into production no test at all
um
so
that's not that good that doesn't give
us confidence the next time
so we want to get started writing these
um service level tests and we should
test the complete microservice and mark
the other ones so what we have is that
we have the Loyalty program and that's
the real code running like it really
does using the real database and real
HTTP and real rapid mq and so on and
then we have a marked special offers
microservice and we'll get a little bit
back to what marked even means it's
maybe
it sounds bigger than it is it's really
small you'll see but what we need is
something that sends an event over
rabbit and we just send a canned event
just something hard-coded because then
we know how the Loyalty program is
supposed to react right
and then the loyalty programs and a the
Loyalty program sends a command over to
a mocked version of the notifications
microservice and a command here really
means it calls that post endpoint that
the notifications service had and then
the mark that we have will just give a
canned response back he'll just say okay
that's fine and that's what we'll do for
now and of course you can do lots more
you could have error scenarios maybe
it's down or maybe it
can't find the user it's supposed to
notify and so on you can test these
scenarios out as well
and the way we can set it up that I find
is quite nice is again
run the other side run the Loyalty
program for real the real code the real
everything and then we have beside that
we have the our well assessed
integration test I'm sorry about that it
should say a service level test process
so I can't even switch from integration
to that
so we have a service level test scenario
running in there and what that does and
that's kind of the mark of the special
offers is it just puts a message onto
that rapidmq
um
which is kind of nothing special that's
also what we do in our real code so just
do the things that we already know how
to do over in the tests
the real code turns around and makes a
request
to the mocked
notifications microservice which we are
actually running inside of the same
process because it turns out that we
know how to take processes and host and
GDP endpoints because that's what we do
in our real code so we can also do it in
our test code so we're just doing the
things we already know how to do
um and then this is a really really
simple endpoint he'll just say OK and
record the fact that it was called and
how it was called
yeah so
a little bit of demo time
and that looks horrible
let's see if that looks better if we
just go out of presentation mode and
back into it
into presentation mode okay so that's a
little bit better
so we have a test here and that's our
um
scenario and the scenario is that we
want to notify an eligible user that's
been the thing all along and we just I
mean
we can refactor code again that's
exactly like we do it in the production
code anyway so we can of course split
things out into methods so we get
something that
looks like the capability like talking
about the capability the business
capability of the service which if we
register a new user and create a special
offer we want to assert that the
notification was sent okay so that's a
capability that we want the Loyalty
program to have that's one of the things
that you do so I mean again without
using a lot of special Frameworks or
anything we are able to write a test
that that that kind of talks in that
language I'm not saying you can just
turn around and show this to your
business people have them write it but
at least you can have a conversation
about what this actually really means
um because if they can just ignore like
the
parenthesis and the await and stuff and
register a new user create a special
offer and a notification was sent okay
we can talk about that
so how are these implemented we have the
register U so just above here if I
remember correctly
there we have it and
this is of course more more Technical
and and not very business friendly but
but and this gets a little bit closer to
the implementation and this is where
sort of we get gets gray box because we
don't know exactly what's going on
inside the uh
um the Loyalty program but we do know
how to talk to the Loyalty program sort
of technically and what we do is that we
take an HTTP client
um there's an HTTP client and we post
something to it and we post to the slash
users with whatever body we need in
order to actually uh create a user so
blah blah blah this calls an endpoint
and registers a user we do the similar
kind of thing for this create special
offer we have this
below down here
and there we go so we create an event
and we probably already have this type
that defines the event because we need
it over in the special offers so this is
not something that we're making up for
the test it's something we already have
and we probably already know how to talk
to rabbitmq because the special offers
microservice does that and that's what
we're doing here so again we're
publishing something onto
rapidmq and then we wait for a while
because now we've registered the user
created a special offer and then the
assertion comes and
then there's this exponential retry
policy here where it's in order to make
these kinds of tests run is is necessary
I'm using the poly framework here sort
of show of hands does people know what
does people know poly okay so I'll not
talk a lot about poly because I think 80
put their hand up
um so we're using poly in order to to do
some retries and and and wait which is
sort of a fast way of waiting and when
it works this will just run through
really really fast and then when it
fails it's slower because we have to
wait for the retries and the timeouts
and stuff but
um
I don't know I'm an optimistic person so
I I tend to like that it's fast when it
works because it probably does most of
the time
um
so there we go so so that's one of these
um service level tests and okay just to
go on on a limb let's try to actually
run it and see what happens and and an
end
running running right
oh I know why yeah this is going to fail
uh yeah there we go so
[Music]
um
yeah and it fails slowly as you noticed
because it had to uh to time out and
everything the re Ese and is that
uh okay you can't really see what this
is but uh you'll have to believe me when
I say that what we have running here in
this uh in this terminal window is a
sorry copy of that loyalty program so we
actually have like we sort of had I
started one up in the test but then I
had a competing one already running and
that grabbed the message of a
rabbit mq so it failed so we saw a
failure now I'll just uh stop that
and take it off screen again
back to the IDE
and rerun and then
hope that
all right yeah you saw it run through
and it's much quicker when it actually
uh actually worked
yeah okay so
now we've established a test that tests
the behavior of a full microservice and
of course this was just a small one but
I mean we can just keep going with these
and actually cover scenarios that are
important for that business capability
now the other part that I also wanted to
test on this service level were the
contracts so the contracts between these
different microservices so
here we were asserting that a
notification was sent but at least
that's what we claimed we were asserting
but since we're only looking at the um
the Loyalty program what we're actually
asserting is that it made a request
towards the notification service that
according to the Loyalty program is
supposed to make the notifications send
a notification
but there's some assumptions here and
that's well there's something that the
notification service works and can
actually send notifications I'm okay
with that at this level because I'm
assuming that service also has tests
so I'm just looking at the Loyalty
program but there's still the assumption
that the way we're calling the
notification service is correct and
that's the contract we're using
um we also want to test that to have a
good confidence this is by no means a
new idea as always Martin Fowler has
written a really good explanation what
is what this is more than 10 years ago
um that's how it is with both things
um
I will talk a little bit about what it
is anyway
so in the test that we just saw
we
had the Loyalty program
send a command to the mock the command
is the post request
we did that in in this manner where it
sends a real HTTP request into the mock
okay
so
[Music]
um
if we want to test the
if we want to test whether that contract
is the right one we can sort of turn
around and go from
the mock
whatever the mark
got into it is kind of the contract or
that's the expectation of the Loyalty
program we can send that into the
notification service
get a real response back and then we can
assert whether that meets the whether
that looks the same as the thing that
the mock responds with and if there's a
discrepancy there then the Mark is wrong
and then we have to change the mark and
see if the Loyalty program now fails and
it might
of course
um so that's really the basic idea of
the contract trust record what we
based on the mark what we what the
expectations are turn around and use
that on the real service at the other
end
um yeah so look putting that on a
drawing we still have the real HTTP
request and then once it gets into the
the mock we can just record uh what
happened and recording what does that
mean that means just dumping it into a
file really
so
last look at
code
and
maybe we'll just actually close this and
we'll be able to see something yes
and we will
switch to another file and we'll switch
switch to the notifications mock so
that's
to No Surprise the implementation of the
marked version of this notification
service and it's really not that
advanced it
and as I said I mean we're able to
create endpoints in our in our services
so we probably also able to do it here
let's again sort of show of hands who
has worked with the with the asp.net
so this is familiar code I think a
controller that can react to an HTTP
post on some path notifications
and it does something it just says yay I
got a a a notification request and then
it returns okay so it says 200 okay and
that's the that's the mocking part and
then the recording part is in here
and the details aren't that important
the important bit is write all text
to a file and the text that we write is
the body of of the incoming request so
whatever the Loyalty program sends in we
write that down
um
and
it just does it to somewhere called
recorded contracts post
Dash notifications.json so there's maybe
also encoded a couple of of assumptions
here as well that based on the name of
the of the file this is because it was a
post request and I'm expecting the body
to be be Json here okay so
um let's take a look at
how that looks in
so we have those here and just that's
what on the last test run that we did
before this is the body that we sent and
this is a body that we wrote then we can
turn around and create a notifications
contract test here and we'll have one
say that says verify loyalty program
contract
and what it does is that
well it has kind of an ugly path here
but it's it's a path to the Json file we
just looked at
and
then it creates an HTTP client sorry
just do it like this create an HTTP
client reads from that file because
that's the body of the request we want
um it does the actual request towards
the actual
um notifications you can see localhost
here depending on where and how you want
to run your test that can be localhost
or you could run it against the test
environment and sort of also a
consideration but that depends a little
bit on how your whole environment is set
up and then lastly we have an assertion
here that we have something to be some
some expected status code that we want
to get rack from the actual
um notification service here and that's
the
that's the second document that we have
in this uh this one so we get that in as
an argument and what we it was okay in
this case and what we have above here
um
so this is X unit I'm I'm using an
assuming again that's probably
so
again show of hands have you worked with
X unit
yeah have you worked with theories next
unit
okay so that that was less than half so
I'm going to explain what that is
um so index unit a test is called a fact
so we decorate it with fact up here and
that's one example that you run as a
unit test then the theory is kind of a
collection of facts and the way that you
do that is that you take the test method
that you already have and then you
parameterize that in this case with a
path to somewhere where we want to read
that body from and unexpected HTTP
status code that we want to get back and
then you could put in these uh inline
data that says Okay so the first
argument I want to be this long string
that's the path and the second document
I want to be HTTP status code okay
then I could just have more of these
um so if I had more contracts I would
just
put them down here I have and now my ID
is telling me that I'm copying code
um
but if I did have more recordings I
could have those be one of these because
it's just exactly the same thing and
that's kind of a point that's why even
though I just have one X angle I I used
a parameterized test in in the shape of
a theory here because it's really I
think you should really strive for
making this test generic and then just
fill in all those contracts and that's
in contrast to the other test we saw
that I don't want to be generic I want
that to be specific to the business
capability and talk in in business terms
this is much more technical just make it
generic and test the contracts that you
get out because that's going to be the
easiest way for you
right
[Music]
um
this was hand-holding the um the the
contract tests which I think you can get
far with you can also look at some
helpful tools uh mounder bank is one
pack there's another packed specifically
for
um
um contract tests amount of bank has a
slightly different uh Focus
why didn't I just use pack then
well because it doesn't do exactly what
I've showed you here but it does
something useful as well it's just more
of a unit test style it does for the
recording so it doesn't quite fit in
with recording from these service level
tests
um but I mean
that might be me
being a little bit not invented by me
kind of that I wanted to be exactly my
way so do take a look at these as as
well it might just be exactly what what
you need in your context
right so that's the whole thing for
service level testers behavioral part
and there's a contract part
below where the unit tests and well as I
already said it's special business as
usual
then we need to prioritize what to test
and we've talked some about this do the
happy path scenarios important happy
path scenarios at the the system level
goes across everything
take a lot more scenarios both positive
and negatives once on the level of the
services and then the the whatever
details you have left do that with with
unit testing that's sort of my rules of
thumb and the way to make that actually
happen to me at least is using outside
in tdd so there's two parts to this the
first is tdd which I am sure you also
heard other people talk about from
stages like this one
um but it's going around in the circle
of writing a test that fails write the
production code you need to make it
succeed and then refactor your code into
something you can actually maintain
going around that circle around that
Circle that's often talked about in the
context of unit test but it works on
other levels as well there's no reason
it only has to be unit tests
um so
with the outside in approach to this we
want to write the high level ones first
and
I find that the really effective way to
do this with well microservices is to do
it exactly at that service level level
it's difficult to start at the system
level but if we do it at the service
level that's doable and we can get some
tests that we can get working we can
drive until that hurts and again there's
gray area here what exactly does that
mean
um it's one of those things that takes
some experience and we kind of know it
when we get there
um
there's usually some setup before we can
have those nice scenarios that says
register a new user
um create special offer so that the
right thing happened and it kind of then
then sort of that that's okay but if you
need to get into something very very
specialized there might be more sort of
okay you have to if you've registered
exactly 101 users with exactly these
permutations of interests or whatever
and then you post this
special offer then something something
and that that becomes more difficult and
then sometimes it kind of feels like I
mean if there's a light switch on the
other side of the stage and you're just
standing over here and then you have a
little stick and you're trying to
there's the lights thing light switch
then that's that's kind of hurtful and
just uh
then then don't write at the high level
switch gears and write a unit test that
you can actually uh put to push the the
light switch so you shift down when it
becomes too difficult and yes that that
that's gray area and yes that takes so
many experience to do
um and then you just repeat
and again everything has been written a
long time ago well a long time long in
Tech terms so this this book uh growing
object-oriented software Guided by tests
that's probably more than 10 years old I
guess I'm not I should have looked that
up beforehand I didn't really good book
and describes this in in detail and it
says object oriented I think if you want
to be more functional because that's
more hip today
the ideas still apply perfectly and then
you can start from that so obviously a
service level of tests and drive your
way into a good test coverage and get
the unit test that you need
and then you might not get exactly the
pyramid shape you might sort of get
going out and then just a fewer unit
tests than the pyramid sort of indicates
but that's okay as long as you actually
get the confidence to deploy as often as
you need which is often with with
microservices
all right so another level of
prioritization was around
um which areas of the whole thing should
we concentrate on and I think
we can use some of the the things that
we can grab from from domain driven
design again where we prioritize where
to put in the engineering effort and the
well the whole effort in in general
um not just engineering and also let
that apply to our testing effort so
there's this thing called a core domain
chart and if you are in this room before
lunch you saw Nick June talk about the
um this as well and well he has lots of
brilliant explanations of really good
ways to use this mine is going to be
shorter and quicker and less brilliant
but it does allow us to do some
prioritization because we have
how much something differentiates our
business at one axis and we have the
complexity of that thing in the other
axis and then we can place things like
say we have
authentication is
quite complex if we try to build it from
the bottom up
um
but everybody does it it doesn't make my
business different from your business
that you're able to log in
we can do notifications
um
so again not very differentiating but if
we do if we're maybe we're good at it so
we send them right at the right time or
we send it in the right channel so
people don't get annoyed
um then we can maybe be better than the
competitor that just spams away
um but maybe not that differentiating
and maybe not as complex as
authentication we have the Loyalty
program okay it's also something that
many companies do so it's not selling us
vastly apart but maybe a bit more
especially if we do it well
um and then we might come up with this
very special personal shopper AI machine
learning whatever
[Music]
um
passwords put together and that might
um also differentiators and might be
sort of complex so we can group these
things into what the core is what what's
supporting the core and what's generic
that we should probably just sort of
either download or buy
and well it doesn't have to only guide
but we download or buy you can also
guide where we put in the testing effort
and I think it all sort of works
together because it does
I had the drawing with the bubbles the
different color Bubbles and it was more
broken down than the green one and
well that was probably the core and
that's where we want to put in the
effort and that's where we also probably
want to put in the the the the the the
testing efforts so these things actually
line up quite nicely
um
then this is not a static view really
um what tends to happen is that
everything moves
back towards a zero differentiation
because
markets move forward so everything gets
commoditized over time your competitors
start doing start copying your things
and you can you copy your competitor and
then
it becomes more and more like so if you
actually want to keep differentiating
you can't leave something alone you have
to actually work with it and that means
that you can with the wide areas you can
you can concentrate something and move
it so it's not just static it's also a
question of
okay we might be okay with notifications
slipping completely into it just being
generic because at that point we can
just retire our own service and buy it
from a third party and that's probably
cheaper than maintaining it ourselves
but the Loyalty program we have lots of
good ideas so we actually want to move
that the other way we want to be better
than our competitors we don't want to
just copy them we want to get ahead with
that one so that's also an input okay so
that means that loyalty program is
probably a good place to get a really
good service level test coverage so we
can experiment we can move fast and we
can really be continuous about it
so back to this one
that the more broken down areas that
suits really well with the types of
tests that I've talked about and luckily
that also tends to go hand in hand with
the areas that we as a business want to
work with and want to do experimentation
with and want to work quickly with so
that's that's pretty good that actually
works together
so last real Slide the uh too long
didn't read slide focus on service level
tests
that's the thing you should remember
that's the gist of it
focus on service level tests and service
level tests are things that functionally
test one complete service with the other
microservices stopped out it tests all
the important scenarios both positive
and negative and it focuses on testing
the business capability that this
service has
then we have the other kind of service
level tests the contract tests that you
also want so you also get the complexity
of what's going on between
the services
and we're actually a bit early so I
guess we have time for questions if
there are some I can't really see
anything so you should just shout if we
have some questions there's a hand over
there
sorry
didn't I write tests that were dependent
on each other
so the contract tests were dependent on
the other ones
yes that's true well that yeah that's a
nice point that that the two styles of
service level tests here are dependent
on the on on each other that the
functional one feeds the test scenarios
into the the second one and usually we
want to have independent tests that's
true I would I'm I handle this by
grouping them so we have the uh the the
behavioral ones that are run with my uh
loyalty program and then at a second
stage in my CI I would take the output
of that and run the the contract once
and and yes that's a a dependency
um and it's a trade-off that I'm willing
to make to get the coverage of both the
behavior and the contracts
no it shouldn't be flaky because because
they they there's a sequence to how we
run it in CI
which kind of is testing the internal to
compatible testing for actions
yes
um so the question over here is that I
talk about testing the behavior and I
think I even mentioned not to Mark too
much and you're saying in the uh growing
up your gory and the software book they
actually do use a lot of mocks
um so somebody's done their homework
very well and you're right
and I don't really agree with that part
of the book I very much agree with the
driving things from the from the outside
in but I think it can be done with a lot
less mocking that than what they do in
in the book so I agree with you that is
a caveat and
maybe that's part of what's just
happened in the past 10 years that we've
realized that we don't need as many
monks
you don't want my hand
yeah so the question is what about side
effects if we run the whole uh service
we're doing something to its database
and stuff like that and that's
persistent so that's side effects I
guess that's the kind of thing we're
talking about yes that's nodding
um and yes that's true the way I handle
this is is leaning on things like
containers and bringing up my service in
a container in my continuous integration
in environment so for each run it will
be a new one
um then I mean there's a trade-off do
you want to bring the container down and
back up again between each test do you
want to wipe the database between every
every test or are you able to run the
whole test Suite with the uh with all
this that's less pure but usually faster
I sort of tend to watch that in practice
that actually good enough that on each
the run of the the test Suite you get a
fresh start but but of course that's
that I mean that's not as pure so I get
that that can be a caveat as well
so yeah it depends kind of answer is
that okay
yeah
I yeah we do have time still
there right there
yes good point yeah so you're saying
this was a right style of contract that
I was looking at so what about read
style where you mostly query data get
something back from a get endpoint
instead of posting something to a a post
endpoint well in I think in a sense
those are
those are almost easier maybe not as
automated but they're more stable in the
sense that that that that now the mock
is very much in charge of what the what
the answer is so it's a question of of
checking the answer that the mock has
against the the real thing as well and
doing it when rolling your own and not
writing too much of a framework like we
just did here I think you'll have a bit
of manual you'll have to sort of keep on
top of keeping that uh up to date and
that's the downside of doing it yourself
I think that's actually one of the
things that pact will do better for you
than than what I'm sort of a leaning
driving towards here so so that could be
one of the reasons for for using that
tool which is a good tool I don't wanna
foreign
yeah so okay the question is that with
the contract says we actually go out and
call another uh service so so is it so
is the isolation level really a service
here and and I
I see your argument that it's that it
that it that it's not so we could put in
a third level and level more and say
that we have the service of its own and
then we have the arrows between them the
uh the contracts that we're that we're
testing and see that as a different
level and I think that supports a little
bit the other question which was aren't
these dependent and and yes so I would
run them actually sequentially doing the
top level ones in one step and the
contract ones in another step in in CI
and that does sort of depend that you
can you could definitely see it as
different levels as well
last question I think if we
have one there's one up there
yes the question is that that with the
contract test we can actually we can
also Express the contracts more formally
with the open API uh we could do it with
the Proto files for grpc there's
different ways of graphql so when we can
specify contracts in different kinds of
ways and then we can base the mark on
that I think all of those are also good
ideas to base your mark on I don't think
it covers everything that you actually
have in the contract because you can
that the contract defines the shape of
the messages that you can send back and
forth but but there's also assumptions
about when I send this message I get
this back and those I think we still
need to to to verify at acquire slightly
more detail level but if we have formal
contracts I think you can get part of
the way there and then you have less
left to do with the the contract test so
so yes that's that that that's also good
to be formal about your contract so I
hope that kind of answered that I think
that's the uh time we had there were
still some hints you could just grab me
afterwards and we can have a
conversation
thank you for listening
[Applause]